Dù bất ngã ngay trước vận đất, nhưng robot này vẫn dành được thành tích nhân hơn
kí lục thế giới bán maratun của một tần đầu tiên con người.
Giải maratun bắt kênh y trào y tròng giữa hàng chục robot hình người và vận động viên con người
được tổ chức sáng mời chính thần tư.
Sau với lên đầu tổ chức năm ngoái, dài trạch đầu tiên từng gặp nhiều sự cố,
khi phần lớn robot không thể hoàn thành và chậm hình nhiều sò phía các vận động viên.
Robot năm nay về chủ vỏ dễ, 8 chăm robot đến từ hơn 1 chăm đội và phần lớn đau
thành trạch đua dài 20 kí lục mẹ.
Robot chiến thắng thuộc hàng ordn ở tư dài 5.5 xa.
Nhân gặp ba lần sau với thành tích hai dờ 1.5 xa của tổ bốt năm ngoái,
thành chỉ còn tổ chức lục thế giới bán maratun của con người.
Là 5.5 xa, dò bản động viên ua gần ra,
J-COP KEEPLY Mũ Tết lập ngày tạm thăm ba tại Lisbon.
Dù các ứng dụng thương mại của robot hình người vẫn trong dài bản thường nghiệp.
Mà chính diễn tại cuộc đua cho thấy thêm năng lớn của công nghệ này,
đưa thấy thêm lào đặc trang mùi trên mùi em đến ứng dụng trang quân xử.